think that by the time a third lockdown
was announced for parts of france that
the government would be
a dab handed it this is what you can do
this is what you can't do but it's been
anything but the case do you think you
understand the restrictions
now in place here in places like paris
now it's it's a little bit more it's a
little bit better
but it's still confusing at some points
there are too much numbers
but the rules not too well it's a little
bit lags
we can do what we like they were clear
enough
they are good at differentiating things
after realizing that they're fuzzy
uh if i'm not mistaken i shouldn't go
out uh after 6 pm
it's after 7 now oh really i didn't know
that at all
we don't understand the new rules at all
for example we are supposed to be in
lockdown
yet we are walking in the champs-elysees
there are a lot of people even though
it's tuesday
normally during lockdown there should
not be so many people yet it is
full there are a lot of people
when the prime minister announced that
16 regions would be heading back into a
lockdown last week
he said citizens would have to once
again
fill out permission forms to show that
they were leaving home
for essential reasons when the new forms
were published they contained so many
options
as to why you could leave home they
caused
widespread confusion
say jean-clause tex how come you allow
me to take a breath 10 kilometers away
but force my dog to stay within one
kilometer of his kennel
i come home from work certificate i pick
up the kids from school
certificate i buy bread certificate
oops it's a little after 7 pm
certificate
luckily i have no dog originally the 21
or so million people impacted by the new
lockdown were told they could travel up
to 10
kilometers from their homes
unfortunately
their dogs could only go one kilometer
mocked and
poked fun at and even the government had
to admit that the form was
complex and soon it was dropped unless
you needed to travel
more than 10 kilometers and want to go
out after the curfew
as yes that's still in place the next
level of befuddlement came as it emerged
that most of the businesses
that thought they would be closed as
they were not essential
like florists the hairdresser and
chocolate shops
were told they could stay open we made
some exceptions such as hairdressers
for french people's morale we did it
because there were professions like
florists that make
half their turnover during spring we did
it for the chocolatiers because it's
easter
so is it really a lockdown or
a lockdown light as it's been dubbed
here
and do people in paris know what they
can and can't do
do you think you can eat lunch with your
friends in the park
yeah i think it it's i think it can be
possible
no they've said it's not they do not
recommend
eating lunch with your friends right now
i think we have the right to eat in a
park with friends
to go out after 7pm under certain
conditions
i think yes but visiting friends at home
no i don't think that's possible after 7
p.m we don't have the ride with the
curfew we don't have the ride
all joking aside a year of bouncing
in and out of lockdowns has certainly
brought everyone to the same feeling
that of being generally fed up and you
can't help but feel that the french
government
is in its own confusion about what we
should
and shouldn't be doing causing perhaps
unnecessary
public anxiety charla zuminski
rt paris
you